i believe i saw recently
on on twitter there is a a monsters
movie coming out directed by rob zombie
by rob daniel zombie yeah and i just
want to point out that if there was ever
a time to introduce a new character to
the cast of the monsters it's their
wacky neighbor neighbor rob zombie oh
he's down the street outstanding you
know like why isn't that a thing
i just found an incredible review of the
charlie's angels reboot it's so i didn't
even know it existed
i remember
like hearing about it i didn't watch it
when it aired but i i watched 15 minutes
of it and was like got it this sucks
i mean have we started i mean i think
we've started this is technically the
beginning of the episode we've already
video's just going yeah man i love it
this is organic this is nina tell us
more about it i'm sure that i cursed at
some point i'm sure i said a bad and
that's okay don't say it
it's it's fine
okay we're we're talking tell us more
about charlie's angels tell nina tell us
about a tv and movie reboot that you
think stunk or that nobody wanted that's
the name of this video yes tell us more
about charlie's angels all right um
do are you familiar with what charlie's
angels is do i have to explain the very
very
very
layered concept to you explain it to me
like i'm a man who wasn't
roughly pubescent at the time the the
the dream not just one
roughly pubescent vaguely there was like
those
never mind i have to go through i have
to go throw up for like an hour
charlie's angels is about three uh very
different extremely hot women who fight
crime in bikinis and are ordered around
by a speaker box that is sentient
question mark it's the same voice in
almost every reboot so i'm just like oh
what's going on here are they cloning
charlie
it's charlie but like are they cloning
one person do they just have like a a
robot in the back somewhere that just
recites things like good job angels or i
don't understand how it works but
whatever it's walt disney spirit
it's always cliffy that's the gist and
it's walt disney's frozen frozen head so
yeah the original 70s version uh it was
seven it was the 70s right am i am i
correct yeah 70s right yeah okay so that
was a big hit and for years everybody's
been trying to capitalize off of it and
it has not returned to tv
that many times and i think this reboot
shows us why so it in the early 2000s it
had two relatively successful movies
with lucy lou cameron diaz and drew
barrymore and i liked those movies
they're campy and they're dumb but they
kind of know what they are and they have
fun with it like the second one opens
with cameron diaz riding a mechanical
bowl that and it sets the tone for the
entire movie sam rockwell is the villain
in the first one and he's really campy
and over the top and it's awesome in the
second one justin throws the villain and
he has an irish accent no reason why he
just does it's great so after those were
successful
they tried to reboot it on tv and they
tried to reboot it with uh minka kelly
who was on friday night lights
and uh rachel oh i'm finding her name
taylor and annie alonza and i'm not sure
what either of them were in before that
but i remembered minka kelly from friday
night lights it is not a good show um it
is very clearly a cash grab the acting
is really wooden one a person will try
to deliver a line and it's pretty clear
that it's supposed to be a joke but then
there's a weird dead silence where
no one talks for a while so you said
that this wasn't one of those like
passion project heartfelt charlie's
angel's reboot you know it's hard to
believe right it's really it's hard to
believe that the million three remake of
a very popular ip was you know
a small indie television project the
problem with the tv show is like it
takes itself too seriously and this show
was on air at the same time as like
revenge or the first season of american
horror story things that are camp and
know their camp and i found this amazing
uh review by one of my favorite critics
uh linda holmes
uh who is a critic for npr and hosts pop
culture happy hour and uh she called in
the headline she called it the
depressing spectacle of a project no one
loves and later she called it uh
a dead unloved pre-chewed blob
so
she basically was like this has no drive
no passion no one wants to be there the
writing is bad the acting is bad this is
a cash grab and it should be camping fun
but it can't even muster the energy to
do that and that's why
bother to be self-aware right it's just
like not right it's it's way too like
we're actually doing this whereas like
charlie's angels is campy the movies are
campy just be camp it's fine it camp
works
and this is just a nothing burger of a
tv show who wants to talk next i'm done
that's such a drag
hey how are you talk to us about tv
reboots nobody wanted i won't say
anything to you brian i've heard what
kind of person you are
i was uh
uh okay so there are a couple of
different ways that you can interpret
that nobody wanted uh
the one that i picked i actually i
really enjoyed i think people in general
kind of
enjoyed it i i think
oh no nobody wanted it in that nobody
watched it or knew that it existed as
far as i can tell
uh
about 10 years back
the year was 2012 there was a a reboot
of the monsters
uh that tried desperately hard to get
made on nbc
it was uh it was made by brian fuller
which makes it kind of amazing that
brian fuller
stayed on board for the whole one
episode without quitting oh i was gonna
say one last thing about charlie's
angels is it got cancelled after seven
episodes which is pretty sleek episodes
yeah forgot that part go on so
brian fuller is amazing we all can
acknowledge that right i tend to agree
yeah uh but he does also have this habit
of not doing the shows that he makes uh
jj abrams syndrome yeah
start a show then leave yeah very very
much yeah over and over and over and
over again no but he he managed to stick
it out through the whole pilot of this
show uh which was called mockingbird
lane
i vaguely remember this oh right it's
neat it's impressive the cast ed
papa monster old daddy monster uh this
time around being played by brian
your guy uh jerry jerry jerry jerry
sliders of connor
o'connor
you mean commander jack ransom from the
hit
star trek lower decks show yes jerry
o'connell dario
joe's apartment let's go
joe's apartment
absolutely not
what are you talking about
this is a movie they made based on mtv
promo commercials about a man who
lives with talking and singing
cockroaches you 500 year old man
this was a laurel and hardy adventure
this was back in the day
you know
one of the early
ribbon in her tacos
[Laughter]
anyway go on go on jerry o'connell
starred as herman munster he did portia
del rossi plays the mom uh she
could see like coming right off of uh uh
better off ted so like she's in full
yeah semi camp weirdness mode uh the the
the real like hero shot though is eddie
izzard plays grandpa mudster and it is
that is pretty perfect the creepiest
performance they they take it all the
way from like you know the the goofy
kind of count chocula version from the
original and they they turn the
character into this
horrifying like he's the disapproving
grandfather character who just does not
understand why
his son-in-law won't raise his child to
be an unrepentant murder machine like
why he why he's uncomfortable with his
child
who's currently in the middle of like
realizing that he might be a werewolf
doesn't understand why he won't teach
the kid to just kill all the neighbors
and does just just a fantastic does
sound like a brian fuller joint
it really is it's that kind of like half
neil gaiman yeah
mythology like meets kind of tim burton
ish it's it's
really delightful it looks also how i
would describe pushing daisies actually
as those two
no exactly yeah and like a little bit of
dead like me and yeah no the
kind of mundane real world meets
the fantastical yeah
yeah it's it's really fun i believe i
saw recently
on on twitter there is a monsters movie
coming out directed by rob zombie by rob
daniel zombie yeah and i just want to
point out that if there was ever a time
to introduce a new character to the cast
of the monsters it's their wacky
neighbor neighbor rob zombie
oh he's down the street outstanding you
know like why isn't that a thing
where he just shows up in his dumb toy
hat and he's like brave and it's like
like good to see you too rob you know
rob's
character from office space where he's
yeah he's just kind of hanging out in
the tank top and like any monster goes
over every once in a while
yeah there's beer in the fridge you
don't tell your parents i think monster
hangs out with rob zombie yeah we'll
have to ask mr zombie himself mr zombie
robert zombie sir zombie zombie esquire
yeah
anyway that was uh that was my pick it
lasted one episode it uh it flopped it
was supposed to get picked up for
serious but nbc got cold feet
and you can find this relatively easily
on like youtube or something i couldn't
find it on youtube but i'm sure that
it's out there somewhere all right i'll
have to track that down that sounds
pretty good um yeah there's a few on our
article on looper.com that i'll run
through briefly before i focus on a few
others we've got a knight rider reboot i
vaguely remember happening val kilmer is
the voice of kit
i enjoyed knight rider back in the day
when i was a young man
we've got a show called
cupid which i never heard of we got a
wonder woman reboot i remember happening
and then never airing yeah
adrian pilecki right mm-hmm
yeah another friday night lights alumna
yeah
yeah i think one one of the ones i want
to focus on here is bionic woman which i
remember oh god jessie plemons is okay
by the way
i'm sure
thank god
so bionic woman is is a movie uh not a
movie a show i remember watching when
the reboot came out i think i checked it
out because it starred um
what the heck is her name um
i know what you're talking about though
starbuck right
what is her name
in the original
starbuck from the new battle star
galactica
was on pretty sad katie sakhoff thank
you and that was why i checked out
bionic woman because i was like oh i
like katie sackov i think she's going to
do a good job oh she played like a side
character in it she was like the bad guy
i think she was oh okay the evil bionic
woman who the bionic woman had to fight
so anyway that was sucked then it got
canceled pretty quick um
like right around the
writers strike too right like it was
yeah
it was yeah
exactly and then dragnet is on here a
show i don't remember being rebooted but
i do remember watching the movie in the
80s starring
dan aykroyd and tom hanks so by that
point were you allowed to were you get
were you getting a discount at the movie
at that
were you point that they didn't follow
the same plot as the radio program from
the 1940s
all i can say is to gather around
what really made me mad was the end that
that they had a wrap
oh you don't stand for that no those
kids no but in all seriousness though
there's it's look it up on youtube there
is a music video
i'm sure it's terrible
it's tom hanks and dan aykroyd doing a
dragnet rap
wow
this has nothing to do with the show but
i'm just saying like the movie was
pretty good but then there was this
great rap um
so there's that
also on our list one that i do want to
focus a bit on is a show called the i.t
crowd which is an a classic british
great show i'm classic now it's just
amazingly funny yeah they rebooted it
they tried it out in america off
american office style and they recast
um
the two of the three leads with richard
iowa sticking around as moss in the
american version
and i don't remember who replaced jen
but i know that the guy that they got to
replace roy was joel mchale which is the
worst casting choice you can make
not because joel mchale is no good but
because he just doesn't
he doesn't fit as a like a loser i.t guy
he's like right got chiseled good looks
yeah and he's a former college football
player and he's incredibly charming and
it's like doesn't fit as a
vaguely
creepy schlubby guy so perfectly
embodied by chris o'dowd in the original
so i watched the first half of the
american reboot and it's really not
funny oh
who made it was it the same people
possibly
i don't know
i'm not i'm not 100 sure on who actually
they tried to do the same kind of thing
with did either of you watch broadchurch
the british
you should it's great i'd say the first
season is like ridiculously amazing and
it's olivia coleman and david tennant
jody whitaker's also on it like it's got
a jam-packed british cast and they
remade it in the states and they put
anna gunn in the uh olivia coleman role
of breaking bad and then they were like
david tennant do an american accent
and it sucked it was a bad show i
probably should have picked that as my
reboot but it was really bad and
everybody was like why would you reboot
this a people can just watch it and b
like why would you not let him at least
be british he he's so good at both being
british and scottish like which he is
scottish but like his uk accents are
perfect his american one not so much and
it was just awkward and weird because
everyone knows him as
you know the doctor or
from being british and jessica jones
like he just don't make him be american
it's weird right it's not great no
and on that subject are to to do a third
british to american import that does not
work rule of threes let's go we're gonna
this is gonna finish it off there's a
show that i love a british show called
task master
yeah it's the f it's one of the funniest
shows i've ever seen it's been very
joyful to me during the pandemic during
lockdown during dark times throw on
taskmaster most of it's on youtube for
free it's so funny it's hosted by
greg davies and alex horn as his
assistant which was actually the show
creator and it gets five british
comedians or regular just generally like
personalities uh famous personalities in
in the uk to do
dumb stuff
and they compete on who can do the best
dumb stuff of what's in front of them
it's so funny
so i was excited to see that there was
an american version i made it through
about five minutes before i turned it
off
they
it's an all-american cast of of
personalities they replace greg davies
with reggie watts right
doesn't work alex horn is there again he
created he helped create the american
version i read that apparently this show
got canceled within the first 23 minutes
of being on tv nice it is wow it's it's
wild because this is a show that has
been exported to various countries
there's the new zealand version there's
i think it's in various european
countries and for whatever reason they
tried it in america and it just was
immediately like this doesn't work and
it's a bummer because it's one of those
things that should work anywhere
if you get the right people but it's
there's something about when
unless you do it right
it's hard for americans to to capture
the essence of what makes a british so
good like even the american office one
of the reasons why people love it so
much is not because it replicates the
british office but because it doesn't
it got better once it stopped trying to
do that right yeah but
it does it just doesn't it just
american taskmaster just didn't work i'm
sorry guys i'll give it another try i'm
sure there's something in there that's
good but man oh man
i better believe you rough stuff i
believe you but anyway you kind of need
somebody like snotty and up their own
butt to be the guy that's in charge and
reggie watts didn't really have that
like yeah
that's very bad casting
who i think would be really good
two two people come to mind
one is dave attell
okay it's just like someone who sits on
a throne and angrily makes people do
things that don't matter yeah and on
that same note mark maron
you know oh you don't see okay so i kind
of thought marc maron too
i i i hesitate to bring it up chevy
chase
oh
right chevy chase
[Music]
baby i know it's a terrible here's the
problem with that here's the problem
with that and i don't think anything i'm
saying is going to be libelous because
it's pretty well documented let's find
out
the whole point of taskmaster is to
pretend to be
an a-hole
yeah and chevy chase is famously
notoriously
i'm not just like to be i'm not trying
to pigeonhole him i'm just saying like
he's got practice playing this character
yeah let's not torture the rest of the
cast with his presence please you know
what twist on the subject of chubby
chase yeah i was going to say joel
mchale
oh yeah that word put him in there yeah
let's do it figured it out call me alex
call me alex horn i'll help you develop
the american version this one's less
than 24 minutes
800 more reboots we've got a full season
perfect
thanks for watching please hit like and
subscribe
[Music]
[Music]
you